Jason Will and I mean, Will and I are the only two people in glasses. Will, you usually wear glasses? I was like a billing, that was like a billing situation. You said Jason and well, no, no, no, sorry, I mean, Will and Jason. No, I said. It's like Will, will calls you and said, listen, next time you mentioned my name along with Jason, you mentioned my name first.
Jason，威尔——我是说，威尔和我是在场仅有的两个戴眼镜的人。威尔，你平时也戴眼镜吗？这就像是一个账单状况。你说杰森和——不不不，抱歉，我是说，威尔和杰森。不，我说的是。这就像是威尔，威尔打电话给你说：“听着，下次你把我的名字和杰森连在一起说时，先把我的名字说出来。”
And you also say and introducing Will and introducing with the, I prefer the. I want to say Will and introducing Will? Yes. No, say, yeah. You're saying that you're only two in glasses. Yeah. Yeah, I was going to say, don't you usually wear glasses. I do.
然后你还说“还有介绍威尔”，我更喜欢。我想说“威尔，还有介绍威尔”？对。不，说，对。你刚才说你们俩是仅有的两个戴眼镜的人。对。对，我本想说，你平时不戴眼镜吗？我戴的。
I wear my reading glasses, but I'm far back enough now from my screen that I don't. So I look younger than you guys. Well, you know, you don't need to see Will today very well because he's doing an audio show called Smartless. And welcome to it. Smartless. Let's hang on a second. Sean Hayes is back in town.
我戴阅读眼镜，但我现在离屏幕够远，所以不戴。因此我看起来比你们年轻。嗯，你知道的，你今天不需要看清威尔，因为他在做一个叫《Smartless》的音频节目。欢迎收听。Smartless。等一下。肖恩·海斯回城了。
No, you can't applaud for yourself. Don't start the applause, Sean. We'll start it. Okay, there you can join it. You know, just... This guy! So happy to have me back. By the way, I have to tell you something.
不，你不能为自己鼓掌。肖恩，别自己带头鼓掌。我们会带头鼓掌的。好，现在你可以加入了。你知道，就是……这家伙！真高兴我能回来。顺便说一句，我得告诉你们一件事。
So happy. I would go, I went out the stage door after a couple of shows, no, after one show. And people were doing that bit. They're like, Bravo! No, in England.
太高兴了。我会去，有几场演出结束后我去了舞台门，不，是一场演出之后。然后人们在演那个梗。他们就像是：万岁！不，在英国。
Yeah, in England, yeah, yeah. You guys. But... The bits travel sometimes. People are listening. But I just got back last night, and I swear to God I weighed about 179, 180 when I left,
对，在英国，对，对，对。你们这些家伙。但是……这个梗有时候传得挺远。有人在听。但我昨晚刚回来，我发誓上帝，我离开时大约179磅，180磅，
I weighed 165. 165 pounds. So you lost 15 pounds while you were in... Well, if you lost it and you're looking for it, I can tell you where to find it. How long will it take to you? get it back. I swear to God for breakfast,
我称了一下是165磅。165磅。所以你在……期间瘦了15磅。好吧，如果你减掉了它又在找它，我可以告诉你去哪找。你需要花多长时间才能把它吃回来？我发誓上帝，早餐，
I just had a bowl of pasta and two pieces of cake because it was Scottie's birthday yesterday. You got a big race tomorrow or something? Wait, wait, it's 9.30 in the morning right now, and you've already had... But to him, it's din, din, time. A bowl of pasta and two pieces of cake.
我刚吃了一碗意面和两块蛋糕，因为昨天是斯科蒂的生日。你明天是有什么重大的比赛还是怎么的？等等，等等，现在是早上9点半，你已经吃过……但对他来说，这是晚饭、晚饭时间。一碗意面和两块蛋糕。
His belly is saying, feed me, it's dinner time. That's right. That's exactly right. Yeah. It was, but, yeah, no, I got back yesterday at like, uh, one in the afternoon, and I went to bed at, 8 p.m.
他的肚子在说：“喂饱我，到晚饭时间了。”没错。完全正确。是的。那是，但是，对，我昨天下午1点左右回来的，然后8点就上床睡觉了。
And I got up at 1 a.m. and then went back to bed. I got up at 7. So I slept like 12 hours. Yeah, you needed it. It's crazy, yeah. And did you have to clean the CPAP machine in between? You're on, you're still on that.
我凌晨1点醒来，然后又回去睡了。我7点醒的。所以我睡了大约12个小时。对，你确实需要。太疯狂了，对。你中间得清洗持续正压呼吸机（CPAP）吗？你还在用那个，
Are you not? No, I lost the weight so I don't need it. Wait, truly? Truly? It was the weight that was... Well, it's a combination of things. I try not to sleep on my back, too, but yeah. Okay.
对吧？没有，我体重减下来了，所以不需要了。等等，真的吗？真的吗？是体重导致的……嗯，这是多种因素结合的。我也尽量不仰睡，不过是的。好吧。
And do you have, like, nails on your back or something so that if you roll on your back, back it pokes you away yeah that would be good strap on some sort of like a nail bed people used to do that they'd like uh they'd put like a tennis ball they'd wrap like a tennis ball on their back no they didn't what he's talking about what do you mean did they look it up oh do the research wait keep going do the reason what you mean research people go i did the research oh did the research what do you mean oh you have access to google yeah wait what website told you that people used to strap a tennis ball to the smaller back uh i read that a long
你的背上有什么钉子之类的东西吗，这样如果你翻身仰睡，它就会戳醒你？对，那倒挺好，绑上某种类似钉子床的东西。人们以前那样做过，他们会……把网球，在背上绑一个网球。不，他们才没有。他在胡说什么？你什么意思？他们真的那样做过吗？查一下啊。哦，去做做研究。等等，继续，做什么研究？你什么意思，研究？人们会去……我做过研究。哦，做过研究。你什么意思？哦，你也能上网？对。等一下，哪个网站告诉你人们以前把网球绑在下背部的？呃，我很久以前读到过。
time ago. Wait, to do what? To do what? I don't know. Somehow, like, put a tennis ball on the, on the, I forget how they do it, like, in their shirt or whatever. So that if they roll onto their back, it's uncomfortable, and then they want to roll back, or it's gentle. They do it with, like, duct tape or something like, or like a tensor bandage or something, I don't know. Don't say fucking
等等，为了干嘛？为了干嘛？我不知道。不知怎么的，把网球放在，放在……我忘了他们怎么弄的了，比如塞在衬衫里什么的。这样如果你翻身仰躺会很不舒服，然后你就会想翻回来，或者说这是一种温和的方式。他们用管道胶带或者类似的东西，或者弹性绷带之类的固定，我不知道。别再他妈的说什么
tenser ever again. You know I think... Your dumb lips. Tenser. Tenser. Stupid. Stop looking at my lips. Profitional Greek. I was doing it this morning. Were you?
“弹性绷带”了。你知道我觉得……你那愚蠢的嘴唇。弹性绷带。弹性绷带。真蠢。别盯着我的嘴唇看。专业级的希腊人。我今天早上就在做这个。是吗？
Yeah, we are a professional grade. The river doesn't damn itself. This country wasn't built in a day. Not a week either. You do Santa Claus too, Will, right? You play Santa Claus. No, it's Batman. Oh, Batman.
对，我们是专业级的。河水不会自己筑坝。这个国家也不是一天建成的。一周也不是。你还扮演圣诞老人呢，威尔，对吧？你演圣诞老人。不，那是蝙蝠侠。哦，蝙蝠侠。
You know what? Batman's Santa Claus. Hey, Sean, we got to get you a nice campaign. What would you like to sling commercials for? Yeah. Call it right now. Is cake a thing? Yeah.
你知道吗？蝙蝠侠就是圣诞老人。嘿，肖恩，我们得给你搞个不错的广告代言。你想接拍什么商业广告？对。现在就点一个。蛋糕算吗？对。
It's a general cake spot. It's all cake products. Makers of America. Yeah. Sean, would you like to go to a cake convention? Wouldn't that be fun? Wouldn't that be great? How was the reintroduction to your dog?
这是一个通用的蛋糕广告。涵盖所有蛋糕产品。美国制造。对。肖恩，你想去参加一个蛋糕大会吗？那不是挺有意思的吗？那不是很棒吗？你重新见到你的狗，感觉怎么样？
Did he give you any attitude? He comes back today in about three hours. Still haven't seen him. How long has it been? Three months. Wow. Yeah. Do you think he's going to give you a little bit of a hairy eyeball?
他对你有什么态度吗？他今天大概三个小时后回来。还没见到他。有多久没见了？三个月。哇。对。你觉得他会不会给你翻个白眼？
He, like, welcome back. Side eye. No, he will. Will he poop in the bed? No. he will, I'll do that. No, he'll, oh, Sean, still? Welcome home.
他会那种，欢迎回来。斜眼。不，他会的。他会在床上拉屎吗？不。他会，我才会那样。不，他会，哦，肖恩，现在还这样？欢迎回家。
No, he's, he'll go, wow, it's you, and then run, and just play, and want to treat. It sounds like Scotty. Listen, Sean, we're so happy to have you back in the fold. We miss you the other night. We talked about you all the time. I know. I know. Are we all hanging out this Sunday?
不，他会，他会说：“哇，是你，”然后跑开，开始玩，想要零食。听起来像斯科蒂。听说，肖恩，很高兴你重新归队。前几天我们都很想你。我们一直在谈论你。我知道。我知道。我们这周天一起出去玩吗？
Yeah. What if you guys were like, sorry, that was it? Last Sunday was it. We are Sunday. But in the meantime, Hollywood Bowl. Oh, well, by the way, sorry, we are going to the Hollywood Bowl. We are going to the Hollywood Bowl. November 15th, Hollywood Bowl.
对。如果你们说：“抱歉，就那样吧？上周日就是最后一次了”呢？我们周日聚。不过与此同时，好莱坞露天剧场。哦，对了，抱歉，我们要去好莱坞露天剧场。我们要去好莱坞露天剧场。11月15日，好莱坞露天剧场。
We got a couple of guests. I got a super big guest. Will, you better bring the noise on your guest. Yeah, I'm going to bring the noise. It's going to be a lot of fun. We're also going to have some special guests as well. It's going to be a lot of fun. Special guest sprinkled around?
我们邀请了几个嘉宾。我请到一个超级大牌嘉宾。威尔，你的嘉宾可得拿出点真本事来。对，我会拿出真本事的。那会非常有趣。我们还会有一些特别嘉宾。那会非常有意思。周围穿插着一些特别嘉宾？
Oh, yeah, we're going to have a lot of shiny moving objects. Am I going to be told about the special guests? Yeah, you've already been told. We've talked about it before, but I mean, you just don't listen. But anyway... Tell me your name one more time. Oh, God. I'm sorry, unless I put it in the context of golf, he doesn't hear it.
哦，对，我们会有很多闪闪发光会动的东西。会有人告诉我特别嘉宾是谁吗？对，已经跟你说过啦。我们之前讨论过，但我的意思是，你根本没听。不过话说回来……再告诉我一次你的名字。哦，天哪。对不起，除非我把它和高尔夫联系起来，否则他根本记不住。
Jason, we already talked about it. We did. Yeah, I know, we already talked about it. I remember? Okay, we're going to welcome our guest. Is this someone that's going to make me nervous? It's really... Well, I get nervous about the secret guest up now.
杰森，我们已经讨论过了。我们确实讨论过。对，我知道，我们已经讨论过了。我记得？好吧，我们要欢迎我们的嘉宾。这个人会让我感到紧张吗？这真的……嗯，对于现在这个神秘嘉宾，我确实有点紧张。
You know this person, and you're going to be nervous about it because she's like a... She's a super wattage megatown, but I've had the pleasure of meeting this person a few times, and I'm always a little starstruck I got to admit. You only meet someone once. She was nominated for her first, Golden Globe when she was 12. Shut. What? Yeah. And has
你认识这个人，而且你会为她感到紧张，因为她就像是一个……她是个超级巨星，但我有幸和这个人见了几次面，老实说我总是有点肃然起敬。你只见过某人一次。她12岁时就获得了她的第一个金球奖提名。闭嘴。什么？对。并且从那以后
kept it going ever since. She's been in countless fantastic movies. Once you start naming him, it's like, forget it. I don't think you do know it is. It's not Jody Foster. She's been in, I don't even know, I can't even but her first nomination was for
一直保持着这种状态。她演过无数出色的电影。一旦你开始报名字，那就，算了吧。我觉得你根本不知道是谁。不是朱迪·福斯特。她演过，我甚至不知道，我都说不上来，但她的第一个提名是因为
interview with a vampire. Shirley Temple. She's just got, uh, Gilman Drop-Drafts, Dead Gorgeous, Spider-Man movie Civil War last year. And Roof Man October 10th is a year. Hi. I fucking guessed it. By the way, that's the first time I think I ever got it right.
《夜访吸血鬼》。秀兰·邓波儿。她刚刚，呃，吉尔曼……《绝望美少女》，去年的蜘蛛侠电影《内战》，还有10月10日的《江洋大盗》（Roofman）。嗨。我他妈猜对了。顺便说一句，这好像是我第一次猜对。
By the Academy Award nominee, you didn't even let me get to them. Sorry, sorry, sorry. You robbed her of that. Hi, Kirsten Dunst. Hi, I'm so happy to be on the show. Does anyone call you KD? Yes. Really?
由学院奖提名者，你甚至都不让我把话说完。抱歉，抱歉，抱歉。你剥夺了她的高光时刻。嗨，克尔斯滕·邓斯特。嗨，我很高兴能上这个节目。有人叫你KD吗？叫的。真的吗？
Yes, I'm a lot of names. Well, listen here. Listen here, KD. You're never going to work for the government because, so I'm in Toronto and I'm walking by her table, you guys. And up she pops. Hey, I'm about to be. on your show. I'm like, hey. That's right.
对，我有很多名字。好吧，听着。听着，KD。你永远进不了政府部门工作，因为，我当时在多伦多，路过她的桌子，伙计们。然后她“噌”地一下跳了起来。嘿，我马上就要上你的节目了。我就像，嘿。没错。
That's supposed to be a secret. So your government job is done. That's amazing. But I was like, okay, I'll play like a big surprise. But you never know. You didn't know. You never know when it's going to happen. You never know when it's going to happen.
这本该是个秘密的。所以你的政府工作泡汤了。太棒了。但我就想，好吧，我要假装这真的是个大惊喜。不过你永远不知道。你根本不知道。你永远不知道什么时候会发生。你永远不知道什么时候会发生。
That's the good news. And you guys were up at Tiff because you were up there promoting Black Rabbit and Kirsten were up there promoting roofman, which I'm really excited. The following day and it was killer. I hear it's amazing. I can't wait to see that movie. It's so good.
好消息是这个。你们当时在多伦多国际电影节（TIFF），因为你们去那里宣传《黑兔》（Black Rabbit），而克尔斯滕去宣传《江洋大盗》，我真的超级期待。第二天，反响超赞。我听说太棒了。我迫不及待想看那部电影。太棒了。
It's like a perfect. like Christmas movie. You know, I love it. Love it, love it, love it. I can't wait to see it. And we're all very excited for it. And we're really excited that you're here. It feels like finally a little bit.
感觉就像是一部完美的。就像圣诞电影。你知道的，我太爱了。爱死、爱死、爱死了。我迫不及待想看它。我们都为此感到非常兴奋。我们真的很高兴你能来。感觉终于有点这意思了。
Couldn't make a deal. Where are you? Where is this? I'm into Lucca Lake. Oh, wow. In the Val. Will and I are about to shank a couple of balls into your backyard.
没敲定档期。你在哪？这是哪？我在托卢卡湖。哦，哇。在峡谷里。威尔和我正准备把几个高尔夫球击到你的后院里。
We are about to be there in a couple hours. There's probably a better way to say that. Yeah. Yeah, don't worry. We'll scrub it. So you were supposed to be on here a couple years ago for Civil War
我们几个小时后就到那儿。可能有一种更好的表达方式。对。对，别担心。我们会剪掉的。所以你几年前本该来这里宣传《内战》的，
and I forget what happened as a schedule thing blah blah blah blah Oh one of you were sick Yeah Yeah yeah yeah for sure Yeah yeah yeah for sure JB
我忘了中间出了什么岔子，是个档期问题巴拉巴拉巴拉哦，你们其中一个人病了对，对，对，对，肯定的对，对，对，肯定的JB
Always battling Wait I love You were so great in that movie That movie was really cool I know I love Civil War It was so good I know I need to see that
总是在与病魔作斗争等一下，我爱死……你在那部电影里太棒了那部电影真的很酷我知道，我爱死《内战》了真的太棒了我知道，我得去看看那部片子
I'm scared to see that I feel like it's probably super good super accurate It's like the same reason You know that movie United 93 That Paul Greengrass
我其实有点不敢看我感觉它可能会超级好超级真实就像是因为同样的原因你知道那部电影《93航班》保罗·格林格拉斯拍的
Yeah sure I'll never see that because what I hear is that it's just too good. It puts you on a plane that's plummeting from the sky for two and a half minutes. I did that movie
对，当然我绝对不会去看那部电影，因为我听说它太逼真了。它会把你直接扔进一架正在从天上急速下坠的飞机里，长达两分半钟。我拍了那部
that's coming out next year, on a plane. No. What is it called? Really? The entertainment system is down. Oh, yes. Wait, what?
明年上映的关于飞机的电影。不是吧。叫什么名字？真的吗？娱乐系统瘫痪了。哦，真的吗？等等，什么？
What is that about? That's the guy who did Triangle of Sadness. Yes, and horse majeure. Ruben Oslin, his name is. You're in a Ruben Oslin film? Yeah, that's like, that was, yeah. You and your hobby are just in about
那是讲什么的？就是拍《悲情三角》的那个人。对，还有《游客》（Force Majeure）。鲁本·奥斯特伦德，他的名字是。你演了一部鲁本·奥斯特伦德的电影？对，那是，那就是，对。你和你的爱人几乎出演了
every great movie you ever want to be in. I know, I know. And your husband, Jesse, Plymouth, who's also a wonderful guy, I had a pleasure of meeting both of you last year or something, just sweet, sweet, super talent. And so you did that movie, The Entertainment System is Down,
你所能想到的每一部伟大的电影。我知道，我知道。还有你的丈夫杰西·普莱蒙，他也是个非常好的人，我有幸在去年左右见过你们俩，真的是既甜美又超级有才华。所以你拍了那部电影《娱乐系统瘫痪》，
which I've just read about, which looks awesome. What is that, like satellites go out or something? Well, what is that? Sound less perturbed about it. No, no, I want to know because it sounds cool. What are they like, the satellites are down or something? Do I still get emails and stuff like that? Can I still do candy crush?
我刚读到过相关报道，听起来酷极了。那是讲什么卫星失效还是什么的？好吧，那到底是什么？对这事儿的语气表现得稍微没那么困惑行吗。不，不，我想知道，因为听起来很酷。它们是说卫星失效了还是别的什么？我还能收到电子邮件之类的信息吗？我还能玩开心消消乐吗？
Does Candy Crush work? By the way, that's real. That's all I do. Wait, what, like, you don't have to, I know we're talking about something on the movie, but tell me what that's, that one's about just, like, briefly, because I love sci-fi stuff or whatever. It's not sci-fi. Oh, yeah, but I mean, like, Doomsday stuff?
开心消消乐还能玩吗？顺便说一句，这是真的。我只会玩那个。等等，什么，就是，你不用，我知道我们在讨论电影里的事，但稍微简单地跟我讲讲那是讲什么的，因为我喜欢科幻题材之类的东西。这不是科幻。哦，对，但我的意思是，是世界末日题材吗？
Well, it's human doomsday, basically, on a plane. Yeah, it's human dooms. So it's called the entertainment system is down because there's no Wi-Fi, there's nothing. Right, right. So you have to deal with each other. Okay, that's what I want to see. John, it's like, you know, you know, like the bar,
嗯，基本上是飞机上的人类末日。对，是人类末日。所以它叫《娱乐系统瘫痪》是因为没有Wi-Fi，什么都没有。对，对。所以你们必须互相面对。好吧，这正是我想看的。肖恩，这就好像，你知道，你知道就像那个酒吧，
you know the bar on Tatooine in Star Wars? Oh, got it, I'm on board. I'm on board. Okay, sorry, I just wanted to put it into context that you could understand. So, Kira's, walk us through a little bit how you, I mentioned that you got your first big award nomination. It was for Golden Globe when you were 12 years old.
你知道《星球大战》里塔图因星的那个酒吧吗？哦，明白了，我懂了。我懂了。好吧，抱歉，我只是想把它放在一个你能理解的语境中。那么，柯尔斯滕，给我们简单介绍一下你是怎么……我提到你获得了你的第一个重要奖项提名。那是你12岁时获得金球奖提名。
How trippy was that? I mean, for a 12-year-old. I don't think I really realized, like, you know what? I was working on Jamanji, and everyone's like, you're going to win, you're going to win. And so don't tell a little girl that, because I didn't win. And then I was crying on, Jane Seymour was next to me, like, for Dr. Quinn Medicine Woman.
当时那种感觉有多迷幻？我是说，对一个12岁的孩子来说。我觉得我当时并没有真正意识到，你知道吗？我当时正在拍《勇敢者的游戏》，每个人都对我说：“你一定会赢的，你一定会赢的。”所以千万别对一个小女孩说这种话，因为我最后没赢。然后我就在哭，简·西摩就在我旁边，演《奎恩医生》的那位。
And I was just, like, crying under the table, pretty much. On the, at the table, on NBC, in front of all the, and everyone's all banged up on champagne, and there's a little girl there looking for someone to hold. Wow.
我差不多就是躲在桌子底下哭。在全国广播公司（NBC）的餐桌上，当着所有人的面，每个人都喝着香槟微醺，而有个小女孩坐在那儿，想找个人抱抱。哇。
Yeah. Did you have a speech all lined up and everything? I don't remember if I did, but. But hey, better to, better to kind of learn that at a young age that, you know, you can't trust the outcome of stuff, you know, later. Yeah, I was going to say,
对。你当时准备好了一整套获奖感言什么的吗？我不记得当时有没有准备了，不过。不过嘿，早点在年轻的时候吸取教训其实更好，你知道，以后就会明白你不能盲目相信事情的结果。对，我是想说，
did it help kind of right size all of that stuff eventually? You know, it's like award stuff doesn't, like, you know, we all know, like the good stuff we all love usually doesn't get nominated or doesn't win. It's like, so really all you have is the experience of making it. That's all you have, really. It's also, it's so odd, isn't it, that, like, you're not, like, the competition of it all, no one's playing the same character. It's like, you know, 100-yard-Dash, you know, everyone's going the same distance
这最终有没有帮你把所有那些东西摆正心态？你知道的，就像颁奖典礼这种事，就像我们都知道的那样，我们真正热爱的好东西通常都不会获得提名或获奖。所以，实际上你拥有的全部只有创作它的经历。那真的是你拥有的全部。而且很奇怪，不是吗？就是，你并不……所有这些竞争，根本没有人扮演相同的角色。这就好像100米短跑，每个人跑的距离都一样，
who gets here quicker. It's pretty clear. I had to audition for the movie on the plane for the entertainment system is down. Oh, you did? Yes. And that feeling, I hadn't been that excited
谁更快到终点一目了然。我不得不为《娱乐系统瘫痪》这部飞机上的电影去试镜。哦，是吗？是的。那种感觉，自从《夜访吸血鬼》之后，我再也没有对争取一个角色感到那么兴奋过了。哇。
to get a role since Interview with the Vampire. Wow. To me, auditioning and getting something is like, that is crazy. When was the last time you auditioned before the Ruben Oslin thing? I auditioned for this movie with Jeff Nichols,
对我来说，试镜并最终得到一个角色，那感觉太疯狂了。在你接鲁本·奥斯特伦德的电影之前，你上一次试镜是什么时候？我为杰夫·尼科尔斯（Jeff Nichols）的电影试镜过，
the director, Jeff Nichols called Midnight Special. The great Jeff Nichols. That was a great movie, Midnight Special. Yeah. Love that movie. So, but wait, so that was like 10 years ago. Yeah, it had been a minute.
导演杰夫·尼科尔斯导演的《午夜逃亡》（Midnight Special）。伟大的杰夫·尼科尔斯。那是部很棒的电影，《午夜逃亡》。对，很喜欢那部电影。所以，等等，那大概是10年前的事了。对，已经过去好一会儿了。
At least. I don't think, yeah. Oh, my God, were you nervous auditioning again? I would be terrified. I did a self-tape. I rolled by myself. Yeah, it is easier. The new world.
至少吧。我不觉得，对。天哪，你再次试镜会紧张吗？我会吓死的。我做了一个自我带子（self-tape）。我自己对着镜头录的。对，这样更容易。新世界嘛。
It was a, yeah, it was all improv. He gave me an improv. And, yeah, I just, you know, put my iPhone. I just taped it on my iPhone. And if you sucked, you just get to do it again. Yeah, I did two takes. I felt I was like, and I didn't watch it. And I just sent it.
那是一个，对，全都是即兴发挥。他给了我一个即兴表演的命题。然后，我就，你知道的，把我的iPhone架好。我直接用iPhone录的。如果你演砸了，就可以重来。对，我拍了两次。我觉得自己当时状态是……而且我都没看回放。直接就发过去了。
Did you ask Jesse to look at it? No, he was away. So no one was there. So you were just all by yourself? Yeah. No way. And so what do you think he was looking for? Do you mind saying what the improv was?
你让杰西帮你看过吗？没有，他当时不在家。所以没有人在场。所以你完全是自己一个人？对。不会吧。那你觉得他在寻找什么？你介意说说当时的即兴表演是什么内容吗？
No, not at all. My improv was a, two people are sitting bored next to each other on a plane. He's asleep with our son. and I am bored and look at his phone. And I discover that he's been cheating on me. So it's like, you know, hanging out on the plane, bored, do the whole like face recognition thing. Right.
不，一点也不介意。我的即兴表演是这样的：两个人无聊地并肩坐在飞机上。他带着我们的儿子睡着了，
And... Wait, not so that's all your... That's all your idea. No, no, this is all he wanted me to do this vibe, basically, the director. And so then I see a memory comes up on the iPhone that is like, to Cotton Eye Joe That song And it's supposed to be like
而我很无聊，拿起他的手机。我发现他在背着我出轨。所以就像是，你知道的，在飞机上闲晃，觉得无聊，做那个面部识别解锁的动作。对。
Him cheating with a bunch of different women Where did you come from? Where did you go? Exactly. So then I see that he's been cheating on me I wake him up But at first I have to go through You know all the emotions and shit And since there was no one else in the improv with you
然后……等等，不，所以这些全都是你的……这全都是你的主意。不，不，这基本上全都是导演想让我呈现的这种氛围。然后我看到iPhone上跳出来一个回忆相册，背景音乐是那首《Cotton Eye Joe》，
As soon as you wake him up And you start to confront him it's over It's over I was like you need to wake up And then I just got pissed And I got up and shut off my phone I love it. I would have loved.
那首歌。然后那应该是……他跟好几个不同的女人出轨的画面。你从哪来？你要去哪？没错。然后我发现他在出轨，我把他叫醒。但一开始我得经历，你知道的，所有的情绪和狗屁。既然即兴表演里没有别人跟你搭戏，
I mean, it's wild to do a self-tape of an improv by yourself. I know. Yeah. That's so weird. I did put Jesse's camera like that because he's always shooting film of our family. So I put his camera nearby, so I had like a, I don't know, a symbol. This is real actuary right now. Of him, of something.
一旦你把他叫醒，开始质问他，就结束了。就结束了。我说：“你得醒醒。”然后我就火了，站起来，关掉了手机。我太喜欢了。我会爱死这个的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. How long have you guys been married? Oh, God. I don't even know. We've been together for about 10 years. We got married after kids. Yeah. Really?
我是说，自己一个人对着镜头做即兴表演的自我带子，这也太疯狂了。我知道。对。太奇怪了。我把杰西的相机架成那样，因为他总是拍我们家人的胶片。所以我把他的相机放在附近，这样我大概就有一个，我不知道，一个象征物。这真是太真实了。关于他的，某个东西。
Three years, maybe? Oh, okay, got it. Yeah. That's great. Wait, talk a little bit about, so doing that audition for that movie by yourself, the nightmare self-tape improv, which is bizarre. But it'd probably been a minute since you said you auditioned for another film,
对，对，对，对。你们结婚多久了？哦，天哪。我甚至都不知道。我们在一起大约10年了。我们是在有孩子之后才结婚的。真的吗？
but how different was when you first started auditioning when you were a kid, basically. And, J.B., you had that experience, too, auditioned. a lot when you were a kid, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah. And what that process was like back then, what it meant to you back then, did you feel were the stakes high, or was it just kind of like after school,
三年左右吧？哦，好吧，明白了。对。太棒了。等等，稍微聊聊吧，就是自己一个人为那部电影试镜，那种如同噩梦般的即兴表演自我带子，真的很诡异。不过正如你所说，距离你为另一部电影试镜已经过去好一会儿了，
go do it and then go do your thing? Yeah, what is that like? Do you put a big thing on it? What do you think, Kirsten? I did. I did because, well, like, okay, we were at the Oakwood Apartments. Oh, my God.
但跟你当年还是个孩子时第一次开始试镜相比，有什么不同吗？而且，J.B.，你也有过那种经历，你小时候也试镜过很多次，对吧？对，对，对。当年的那个过程是什么样的，对当年的你来说意味着什么，你当时觉得赌注很大，还是仅仅觉得就像放学后，
And I was going to normal schools. For my sister, for Tracy, The Oakwood Apartments is a complex where a lot of actors would stay while they're interested. Because you can rent it monthly. Yes. I'd come out for pilot season, a bunch of years in a row and stayed there. Same. Yeah.
去试镜然后做你自己的事？对，那是什么感觉？你会把这看得很大吗？你怎么看，克尔斯滕？我是的。我是因为，好吧，就像我们在奥克伍德公寓（Oakwood Apartments）。哦，天哪。
Oh, same. Where were you coming from? I'm from New Jersey. Okay. Yeah. All right. You guys could have careful. Yeah.
我当时在上普通的学校。为了我妹妹，为了特雷西。奥克伍德公寓是一个很多演员在寻找工作期间居住的综合公寓。因为你可以按月租。对。我连续好几年为了试播集季（pilot season）来到这里并住在那里。我也是。对。
So we would come out, yeah. We probably covered. Remember you used to have that sign on the back, the one on Barham, right? Yeah, yeah. So, and the back gate one had it, as you were waiting for the gate to open, there was a little sign on the gate as it moved that said, smile it. showtime. Oh, God, I don't remember. And I remember thinking, like, how soon do you want me to take my own life?
哦，我也是。你们当时从哪来？我来自新泽西。好的。对。好吧。你们俩当时得小心点。对。
So depressing. Not getting any jobs. Go get them. Oh, God. Anyway, so you come out your... So you're Oakwood. So you're at Oakwood with your... I'm an Oakwood. My mom, my brother, and my grandma. Wow. But I would go to normal school. I went to Laurel Hall in the Valley. Sure. Where I met my best friend. So I had like a normal-ish life because I never was home tutored or anything. Yeah. But yeah, auditioning was when it was a big role, like I remember this, it was like I auditioned for interview with the vampire, auditioned for the secret garden, and I didn't get the
所以我们会来，对。我们可能去过。还记得巴勒姆（Barham）街后面的那个标志吗？对，对。所以，后门那个也有，当你等着门打开时，门动的时候上面有个小标志，写着“笑吧，showtime到啦”。哦，天哪，我不记得了。我当时心想：你到底希望我多快自杀？
secret garden. And I remember sobbing about them. Wow. But now, but was it, did it get more stressful as you got older? No, because I think because I got success from interview, I didn't have to audition for a long time. Like, I auditioned for little women, but it wasn't frequent enough to traumatize me. I auditioned for Spider-Man was the big next one that I auditioned for. Uh-huh.
太令人沮丧了。找不到工作。去争取吧。哦，天哪。不管怎样，所以你出来……所以你在奥克伍德。所以你和……住在奥克伍德。我在奥克伍德。有我妈妈、我哥哥和我外婆。哇。但我会去上普通学校。我去了峡谷里的劳urel霍尔学校（Laurel Hall）。没错。我在那儿遇到了我最好的朋友。所以我过着一种相对正常的生活，因为我从来没有在家接受过家教什么的。对。但对，试镜就是当遇到大角色的时候，就像我记得这个，我去为《夜访吸血鬼》试镜，为《秘密花园》试镜，但我没能拿到《秘密花园》。
Did you get it? I did. And what's that? So he's jet lagged, forget us that he's just cheeky. Even though he's not in England anymore, he's still cheeky. J.B., did you ever, did you ever, I mean this honestly, did you ever sob or have that thing, that pressure? I remember you talking about the pressure of getting a job because, it was the family business.
我还记得为那些事哭得泣不成声。哇。但是现在，随着你长大，这变得更有压力了吗？没有，因为我觉得由于我从《夜访吸血鬼》中获得了成功，很长一段时间我都不用去试镜了。比如，我去为《小妇人》试镜过，但频率没高到给我造成心理创伤的地步。我试镜《蜘蛛侠》是之后的大动作。嗯哼。
I never cried, but what was worse was that I'd be so paralyzed with fear on the way to auditions when I got to be in my 20s because I literally needed the employment. I needed, you know, it wasn't just like fun when I was like a little kid and I get to skip school and all that stuff.
你拿下了吗？我拿下了。那是怎么回事？所以他有时差，别管他，他只是有点调皮。尽管他已经不在英国了，他还是那么调皮。J.B.，你有没有，你有没有——我是认真的——你有没有哭过，或者经历过那种事，那种压力？我记得你谈过找工作的压力，因为，那是家族生意。
And then it became like, you know, well, this is my occupation. It's how I make... Did you support your family, Jason? I contributed for sure, yeah. Yeah, yeah. Did you, Kirsten? I didn't have to
我从来没哭过，但更糟糕的是，当我20多岁的时候，在去试镜的路上，我会恐惧到瘫痪，因为我真的需要这份工作。我需要，你知道的，这不像我小时候那样只是好玩，可以逃学之类的。
It started out as like Fun, college money, whatever And then my parents got divorce And then it was a little like Well, you're making the most money So my mom lives in my back house, okay? Aw, that's sweet Yeah, I'm a good daughter
然后它变成了一种，你知道的，“好吧，这是我的职业。这是我赚钱的方式……”你养家糊口吗，杰森？我确实出了一份力，对，没错。对，对。你呢，克尔斯滕？我不用。
That's good, that is sweet, yeah, I love that Very, very cute We'll be right back And now back to the show All right, so you're in Toluca Lake. What's going on? Is Jesse in town? Or are you, you guys must take turns single parenting?
一开始就像是好玩，大学基金什么的。然后我父母离婚了。接着就有点像是，好吧，你赚的钱最多。所以，我妈妈住在我的后屋里，好吗？啊，真贴心。对，我是个好女儿。
I was going to get into that. Yeah, it's tough. Yeah, it's so hard. I had a real moment last night. I just went to my friend's house. I was like, I can't parent alone tonight. I just can't do it. Just leave a bunch of milk and crackers out.
那挺好，真的很贴心，对，我喜欢这样。非常，非常可爱。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。好的，所以你住在托卢卡湖。最近怎么样？杰西在城里吗？还是说，你们俩必须轮流单亲带娃？
Well, I took them with me. Oh, gotcha. No, no, I just brought them all. J.B., what do you think she's doing over there, man? That's how I grew up. Wait, how many kids and how old? I have two boys, but like literally I'm getting ready for this and I get this sign.
我正要切入这个话题。对，太难了。对，太难了。我昨晚真的破防了。我只是去了我朋友家。我说：“我今晚一个人带不了娃了。我真的做不到。”只要留下一堆牛奶和饼干就行了。
I need you. Him sad, me with the door shut. Oh. Look at that drawing. Sean's dog drew a similar picture. Wait, did he make that joke? So, listener, this is a picture of Kirsten inside one room with the door closed and then her son on the outside.
好吧，我把他们一起带上了。哦，明白了。不，不，我只是把他们全带来了。J.B.，你觉得她在那边在干嘛，伙计？我就是这么长大的。等等，几个孩子，多大了？我有两个男孩，但就像我字面意思说的，我正准备做这个，然后我收到了这个纸条。
Upset. And so did he slide that under the door? Yes. No. Mommy come out. Yeah. And I let them sleep in bed with B.U. and Jesse's not here. Like, I am like, actually, you know who we watch, Will, is the Lego Master's show.
“我需要你。他伤心，我把门关上。”哦。看看那个画。肖恩的狗也画过一幅类似的画。等等，他是在开玩笑吗？所以，听众朋友们，这是一幅画，画的是克尔斯滕待在一个关着门的房间里，而她的儿子在外面。
Nice. I'll put you right out, right? Yeah, no, I use that. That's like, yeah. It's like a sugar crash. It's fun. It's calming. It's a fun thing to watch with.
很不高兴。所以他是把这个从门缝底下塞进来的吗？对。不。妈妈出来。对。我让他们和B.U.一起睡在床上，而且杰西不在。就像是，我简直——实际上，你知道我们在看什么吗，威尔，是那个乐高大师（Lego Masters）节目。
kids, isn't it? It's a very fun family show. So are you guys always so one of you is pretty much is it safe to say always working and that's why you have to just or do you have like a schedule? No, we had the summer together. It's like whoever's up next like whatever
太棒了。我直接推荐给你，对吧？对，不，我用那个。那就像是，对。就像是糖分摄入过量后的崩溃。很有趣。很安抚。是一个很适合跟孩子们一起看的好节目，不是吗？
we're still trying to figure it out you know but I mean it's really hard it's really hard so yeah they're four and seven so it's like and they're two boys. It's a lot yeah it's a lot. Yeah I
这是一个非常有趣的家庭节目。所以你们俩是不是总是……其中一个人基本上可以说总是处于工作状态，这就是为什么你们只能这样，还是说你们有个时间表？不，我们夏天是在一起的。就像是轮到谁就是谁，不管怎样……我们还在努力摸索，你知道的，但我的意思是这真的很难，真的很难。所以，对，他们四岁和七岁，所以就像是……而且是两个男孩。挺多的，对，挺多的。对，我
I've been there, been there and done that. Have you thought about, and you can shut us up any time we're getting too personal. Have you thought about the, shut up? I didn't know that was an option. Fucking shut up.
经历过，经历过也做到了。你们有没有想过——如果觉得我们管得太宽随时可以让我们闭嘴——你们有没有想过……闭嘴？我不知道还有这个选项。他妈的闭嘴。
This is the fucking greatest day on the podcast. Shut the fuck up. Shut the fuck up. About the possible convenience of homeschooling, you know, where you guys just drag them around. I don't want my kids be weird. I know, I know, exactly.
这是播客里他妈最棒的一天。给老子闭嘴。给老子闭嘴。关于在家上学（homeschooling）可能带来的便利，你知道的，就是你们可以把他们带在身边。我可不想让我的孩子变得古怪。我知道，我知道，完全同意。
I'm with you. They need that social interaction. probably right yeah no i know plenty of parents so that have done it successfully so who are we to judge but it i i definitely benefited from getting getting uh away from adults and into school and being with kids when i wasn't working it was yeah and they would just you pick up the great news was the bus that picked you up was the school yeah that turns out jason went to school on a bus and he didn't drop out high school. He was dropped off from high school. It is true. It's going to be a fun chapter
我和你一样。他们需要那种社交互动。可能吧，对，没错。我知道有很多父母成功地做到了这一点，所以我们算老几，不予置评。但我——我绝对受益于离开成年人，走进学校，在不工作的时候和孩子们待在一起，那确实是……而且他们会——你去接他们，好消息是接你的校车就是学校……对，结果证明杰森是坐校车去上学的，他可没有从高中辍学。他是被校车送到高中的。确实如此。那将是书里有趣的一个章节，
in the book one day. Oh, God. Oh, my gosh. Oh, my gosh. Don't you cry. Don't you cry, J.B. No, I'm not crying. You're crying. So, and you kind of mentioned you didn't really have to audition anymore, and you kind of did for little women, but then you just started doing, and you mentioned you get nominated, I guess, when you're doing Jumanji, which was a huge hit.
总有一天。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。别哭。别哭，J.B.没有，我才没哭。是你在哭。所以，你刚才提到你基本上不用再去试镜了，你为《小妇人》试镜过，但后来你只是开始工作，你提到当你拍《勇敢者的游戏》时获得了提名，那可是一部超级大热片。
It's massive. Yeah, massive. And you just, you kind of went on this running of, like, just being in these big, massive movies, and you're young. Yeah. So you're like, oh, well, this is my reality. It wasn't, though. Like, I was almost embarrassed. Really? Really?
太轰动了。对，太轰动了。然后你，你就开始了一段……就好像一直参演这些超级大制作电影，而你当时还很年轻。对。所以你会觉得，哦，好吧，这就是我的现实生活。但其实并不是。比如说，我甚至觉得有点尴尬。真的吗？真的吗？
I think so. And I didn't really, I, like, had a blocker up, I think, that didn't compute what I was doing. Plus, what am I doing? I'm going to school. I have my best friend. We're in our own world. Like, I really lived in a very little, like, school bubble, you know? I would do my thing.
我想是的。而且我真的没有，我，好像竖起了一道屏障，我觉得它无法计算我当时在做什么。另外，我在干嘛？我在上学。我有我最好的朋友。我们在我们自己的世界里。真的，我生活在一个非常小的学校泡沫里，你知道吗？我做我自己的事。
I know, but didn't it get weird, like, on the weekends and you go to your school parties and all the kids at the party and you're just trying to, you just feel like you're just one of the kids at the weekend party and then like, oh, hey, that's that girl from the movie I saw last week. Like, wasn't that to me? No? Really? Come on.
我知道，但周末的时候不会觉得很奇怪吗，你去了学校派对，派对上的所有孩子，你只是努力让自己感觉就像周末派对上的普通孩子之一，然后突然有人说：“哦，嘿，那不就是上周我看的那部电影里的那个女孩吗？”难道不觉得是这样吗？没有吗？真的吗？拜托。
You were pretty famous, though. Yeah, but I don't know. They didn't do that to me at school. Yeah. I don't. Maybe it was like a, I was very. normal I didn't come into school like hey look at me you know I was I was embarrassed so right yeah like talk to me about that what do you mean embarrassed like embarrassed because of the attention that you
不过你当时挺有名的。对，但我不懂。他们在学校里不会那样对我的。对。我不知道。也许就像是，我非常普通。我来到学校不会摆出一副“嘿，看我”的姿态，你知道的，我很尴尬，所以……对，就像是……跟我聊聊那个，你什么意思？尴尬？是因为电影带来的那些你并不想要的关注而感到尴尬吗？
got that that was a byproduct of the movie that you weren't looking for I think I just didn't want to be singled out at school as anything other than another student there and high school too like I didn't want anyone to call me out or be like so I underplayed myself were you already through high school when you did bring it on? It was senior year, the summer before senior year. I love that movie so much. Like the ultimate cheerleading high school movie, too,
我觉得我只是不想在学校里被当成除了普通学生之外的任何人，高中也是如此——我不想任何人把我挑出来，或者说……所以我尽量低调。你拍《魅力克拉克帮》（Bring It On）的时候已经高中毕业了吗？那是高三，高三前的那个夏天。我太喜欢那部电影了。简直是有史以来最棒的啦啦队高中电影，
of all the time. But we didn't know that at the time. That was like a little San Diego Who Cares movie, the Universal. You know, it wasn't like, no one knew that that would be a bit. Do you still remember some of the cheers? You know I do. Do you do it? Do you ever
没有之一。但我们当时并不知道。那就像是一部环球影业出品的、微不足道的圣迭戈“谁在乎”电影。你知道的，那并不是说，没有人知道那会成为一个梗。你还记得一些啦啦队的呐喊口号吗？你知道我记得的。你会跳吗？你有时会在片场讽刺性地
do it sometimes ironically on set when you're trying to ramp up the crew in the past, I could do it's a fucking night shoot and it's time to keep going. Ready, okay. Five, five. I did it for my sons yesterday because we went to this 25th anniversary.
跳一段吗？当你试图在过去给剧组打气的时候。那他妈是一场夜戏，而且必须继续拍下去。准备，开始。五，五。我昨天还为我的儿子们跳了一段，因为我们去参加了一个25周年纪念活动。
Well, we went to this 25th anniversary, bring it on thing on Sunday night. No way. And they had good pop-pops. So I brought some pop-pops home and I was like doing cheers for them and spelling their names. That's the only show. Those are the only people that are going to get that show.
对，我们周日晚上去参加了一个《魅力克拉克帮》上映25周年的活动。不会吧。他们有那种拍立得照片（pop-pops）。所以我带了一些拍立得回家，我当时就为他们跳拉拉操，还拼出他们的名字。那是唯一的演出。只有他们才会看那种表演。
Did they like it? Yes, my son was like looking at me like I was like, Whoa, like a golden goddess. I didn't know you could do this mom. You don't want him to like it too much. Cheers squad. Yeah, I actually, a mom recruited me to start a cheer squad at the school. Really?
他们喜欢吗？喜欢，我儿子看着我的眼神就像是在看……哇，就像在看一个金色女神。我不知道你还会这个，妈妈。你可别让他太喜欢了。啦啦队。对，事实上，有个妈妈招募我在学校里组建一个啦啦队。真的吗？
Oh, wow. Yes, yes, yes. Oh, I'm going to do it. I'll do it, yeah. I love that you're going to do that. I do love that show. That's so cool. That's show cheer on Netflix.
哦，哇。对，对，对。哦，我要去。我会去的，对。我太喜欢你要去干这个了。我真的很喜欢那个节目。太酷了。Netflix上那个叫《啦啦队》（Cheer）的节目。
Oh, yeah. That's right. That's real good. I know. I know. Is it? Is it dark? What is it? Well, it got dark. A guy got arrested for bad things. Yeah.
哦，对。没错。那个真的很好看。我知道。我知道。是吗？很黑暗吗？讲什么的？嗯，后来变得挺黑暗的。有个家伙因为不好的事情被捕了。对。
Really? Wait, I didn't see that one. Well, no, no. Did that happen on the show or away from it? Off the show, off the show, yeah. Oh, got it. Wait, Shawnee, did you ever experiment with Cheer Squad? No, but my sister was a cheerleader.
真的吗？等等，我没看那个。嗯，不，不。那是发生在节目里还是节目之外？节目之外，节目之外，对。哦，明白了。等等，肖恩妮，你以前尝试过啦啦队吗？没有，但我姐姐是个啦啦队员。
What's your sister's name? Her name is Tracy. Okay. With an EY or is it just why? In the EY, yeah. And she... Where she lives? She lives in Wisconsin.
你姐姐叫什么名字？她叫特雷西。名字是带EY还是仅仅是Y？带EY的，对。她……她住在哪？她住在威斯康星州。
Does she know much about that? The biz? Yeah. No. Do you have to explain stuff to her ever? Yeah, anytime you guys can think about it, just make sure. Continue. And so she would have, she would do cheerleading things, and she would do pompons.
她对那个了解很多吗？那个圈子？对。没有。你有什么需要向她解释的吗？对，随时随地你们想到了什么，确保……继续。所以她会，她会做啦啦队的事情，她会用手球拍（pompons）。
Oh, wait, do I have the photo? No. And there's a picture of me and her. I love you to grab a baton. I'm so excited. So I learned how to do the baton at a young age. What is the little thing, the dude in front of the band, the marching band? It's not...
哦，等等，我有那张照片吗？没有。有一张我和她的照片。我太爱指挥棒了。我太兴奋了。所以我很小的时候就学会了玩指挥棒。乐队前面那个拿着指挥棒的人叫什么来着，军乐队的领队？不是……
The stick. So it's got a pointy stick and then a little ball at the top. a little ball at the top. Is that also a baton or just a staff or like a band leader stick? Or staff. Yeah, stuff. Yeah, something like that. Anyway, Kirsten.
这根棍子。所以它有一根尖头棍，顶部还有一个小球。顶部还有一个小球。这也是一根指挥棒还是一根权杖，或者像乐队指挥的棍子？或者权杖。对，权杖。对，诸如此类的东西。总之，克尔斯滕。
I'm happy chilling. Yeah, you don't get to talk on this show. I love it. Wait, so tell me, wait, because like Will said, you've done so many gigantic movies, is there, I know you don't want to, they're all important to you and all of your work is important. But they're all different, like, sort of different styles. Like, you really bounce around. You can't be pegged to one thing.
我享受轻松。对，你在这个节目里不能说话。我喜欢这样。等等，所以告诉我，等等，因为正如威尔所说，你拍过那么多超级巨片，有没有——我知道你不想，它们对你都很重要，你的所有作品都很重要。但它们都很不同，比如说，风格各异。就像，你真的在不同类型间跳跃。你不能被定格在某一类事情上。
Like, you've did, you've had these, like, it almost feels like different phases. Well, they're just different roles, I guess. That's what it is. Yeah. But is there one where you're just like, you know what? That was the greatest experience of my whole career so far. And you just thought, like, there's no way it can get better than that. Not result necessarily, but just, yeah, yeah.
就像，你拍过，你经历过这些，就感觉像是不同的阶段。嗯，它们只是不同的角色，我想。就是这样。对。但有没有哪一部让你觉得，你知道吗？那是我整个职业生涯迄今为止最棒的经历。然后你觉得，不可能还有比那更好的了。倒不一定是结果，而是，对，对。
No, yeah, no, the experience, the experience. Huh. I don't know, because, like, movies aren't fun to make. You know what I mean? Right, right. Yeah. So, but, God, I, I really liked. He'll take the worst experience.
不，对，不，是经历，是经历。哈。我不知道，因为，电影拍起来一点也不好玩。你知道我的意思吗？对，对。所以，但是，天哪，我，我真的很喜欢。他会把最糟糕的经历拿出来。
I liked making melancholia. I don't, it was like, it was like this little isolated. It felt like we were doing a play. We all lived in this small town in Sweden and this hotel slash housing place. And it was, it was just like cozy and really calm and so. So, when I'm at, like, comforting. I don't know. It was just, I just felt like, oh, this is what it could be like.
我喜欢拍《忧郁症》。我不，这就像，这就像这个小小的、孤立的。感觉我们像在排话剧。我们都住在瑞典的一个小镇上，在这个酒店兼住宅的地方。而且它，它感觉很舒适，真的很平静，所以。所以，当我处于，像是，令人慰藉的状态时。我不知道。这只是让我觉得，哦，生活本该如此。
Lars von Trier? Yeah. Yeah. Now, then you have a fam. Go ahead. Well, I'm going to ask a dumb question. Surprise. When you, I'm not sure about going to Sweden to Norway.
拉斯·冯·特里尔？对。对。现在，然后你有个家。说吧。嗯，我要问个蠢问题。不出所料。当你去——我不确定是去瑞典还是挪威。
Okay. Why? Because of the light. I can't wait for this. I feel like a get very sad because if I'm there, during the time of the year when the sun only comes up for a couple of hours.
好的。为什么？因为光线。我已经迫不及待了。我觉得我会变得很悲伤，因为如果我在那里，正值一年中太阳只出来几个小时的时候。
I'm going to feel like a new player. They call it winter. Is it winter? I can't. I'm sure I can do it. No, it's very, we were there in the summer, so we had a beautiful Swedish summer. Almost worse, right?
我会觉得自己像个新玩家。他们管这叫冬天。是冬天吗？我受不了。我确信我能行。不，非常，我们在夏天去的，所以我们度过了一个美丽的瑞典夏天。几乎更糟，对吧？
Because the sun never goes down. It did. It's weird. I went one time early July and I flew from here and I landed there that had crazy jet lag and then woke up at 4 a.m. A phone call came through
因为太阳从不落山。确实落了。很奇怪。我曾有一次在七月初去过，我从这儿飞过去，在那里降落，有时差，然后凌晨4点醒来。一个电话打进来
and I step outside and it's blaring sun and it's like 5 to 4 a.m. And it felt like it was noon and I was like, what the fuck? Where am I? It was so discombobulating. I feel bad.
我走到外面，阳光刺眼，差不多是凌晨3点55分。感觉就像中午一样，我就想，他妈的？我在哪？太让人晕头转向了。我感觉不好。
I mean, because of that, Kirsten, because you have a family now and Jesse works and it's this very artistic, you know, you're just around it all the time and the schedules, do you still enjoy going to another country
我是说，正因为如此，克尔斯滕，因为你现在有了家庭，杰西也要工作，这是一种非常有艺术气息的，你知道的，你一直身处其中，还有档期问题，你还喜欢去另一个国家
for three, four, five, six months, whatever it is, to work. I mean, those experiences, do they still fill you up? Well, I didn't enjoy Budapest. Let's just put it that way. I really did not. Well, our son, we all went as a family. We enrolled them in the international school there.
呆上三、四、五、六个月，无论多久，去工作吗？我是说，那些经历，它们还能充实你的生活吗？嗯，我不喜欢布达佩斯。我们这么说吧。我真的很不喜欢。嗯，我们的儿子，我们全家都去了。我们把他在那里的国际学校办了入学手续。
Yeah. And then my son had appendicitis and emergency surgery and then recovered for a week and then had a blockage. So basically my time in Budapest was, horrible. It was horrible. God, that's so young to have an appendicitis. Usually it takes years to fill that thing up. I don't know. I was
对。然后我儿子得了阑尾炎，做了紧急手术，接着恢复了一周，然后又肠梗阻了。所以基本上我在布达佩斯的时光，太可怕了。太可怕了。天哪，那么小就得阑尾炎。通常得花很多年才能把它填满。我不知道。我当时
like, everyone's like, drink the water there, so I was like, yeah, the water's great. So now I'm freaking out, like, was it the water? I don't know. Wait, what movie was that on? That was on the airplane movie. Oh, oh, oh, no shit. No shit. Oh, wow. So this first part, I mean, everyone's had a shit year, it seems like.
就像，每个人都说，喝那里的水，所以我当时就想，对，水很好。所以我现在吓坏了，在想，是水的问题吗？我不知道。等等，那是拍哪部电影的时候？那是拍飞机那部电影的时候。噢，噢，噢，真的假的。真的假的。噢，哇。所以第一部分，我是说，每个人都经历了糟糕的一年，似乎是这样。
But like, the first part of the first part of our year was pretty so but but to sean's question like do you um are you a are you a big nester like what like now that you're back home do you love just like not going anywhere yeah i don't go anywhere yeah i say in my radius of school drop-off and neighborhood restaurants i don't i don't lose the valley it's nice isn't you go in there to that bob's big boy you get in there oh i love that place i like the car nights but i never want to eat there bob's big boy oh i love it i love it Sean cool it man Yeah, okay, it's not going anywhere.
但就像，我们这一年的第一部分，第一部分相当所以但是但是对于肖恩的问题，就像你，嗯，你是一个，你是一个很喜欢宅家的人吗？就像什么，就像现在你回到家了，你是不是喜欢就待着哪也不去？对，我哪也不去。对，我说在我的活动半径内，也就是学校接送点和社区餐厅，我不会，我不会离开山谷区。这挺好的，不是吗？你去那个鲍勃大男孩餐厅，你进去，噢，我喜欢那个地方。我喜欢汽车之夜，但我从不想在那里吃东西。鲍勃大男孩餐厅，噢，我喜欢它，我喜欢它。肖恩，冷静点，伙计。是的，好吧，这事还得再折腾20分钟。我昨天其实就在伦敦。今天星期几？对，我刚刚结束，完成了我的最后一场演出。我在那儿演了一部话剧，克尔斯滕，那是……终于，一个美好的道晚安。对我们来说一个美好的道晚安，伙计。而且每个星期天，我们都会去五人组汉堡店，对吧？
We're not going to be done with this for another 20 minutes. I was in London just yesterday, actually. What's today, Tuesday? Yeah, and I just finished, did my last show. I did a play there, Kirsten, and it was... Finally, a final good night. A final good night for us, man. And every Sunday, we would go to five guys, right?
那个汉堡店。对，对。然后威尔在我和斯科特去五人组汉堡店的路上给我们打视频电话。他说，你们去哪儿？我说，他说，你们正走去五人组汉堡店买汉堡。我说，对。他说，看你们俩这架势，你们从那儿走出来的时候。你们走出来的时候看起来得像十个人或者别的什么。
The burger place. Yeah, yeah. And so Will FaceTime me and Scotty on our walk to five guys. And he goes, where are you going? I go, he goes, you're on your way to five guys to get a burger. I go, yeah. He goes, by the look of you both, you're going to walk out of there. You're going to walk out of there looking like 10 guys or something.
更像十个人，我说的对吧？我说的对吧？这东西？太蠢了。但我喜欢，我喜欢那些老式汉堡店，比如鲍勃大男孩餐厅之类的。山谷区有很多这种店，像山谷区那些真的很棒的老式披萨店。我要说点有争议的话。还有凯利贡斯呢。
More like 10 guys, am I right? Am I right? Is this thing? It's so stupid. But I love the, I love those old burger joints like Bob's Big Boy and stuff. And there's a lot of them in the valley, like old, like pizza places in the valley that are really great. I'm going to say something controversial. There's Kelly Gons, too.
你去过奇利约翰斯吗？那个地方真是一个古董。它在……就在它街对面？河滨路和冷水峡路。是那个地方吗？不，奇利约翰斯在……是木兰路还是伯班克路？
Have you been to Chili Johns? That place is a real relic. It's on... Right across the street from it? Riverside and Coldwater. Is that the place? No, Chili Johns is on... Is it Magnolia or a Burbank?
我觉得是伯班克路。而且非常酷，很老派。你们去过苹果派餐厅吗？你们一定去过苹果派。对，当然。但那在山的那一边。对，苹果派餐厅是最棒的。那在皮科街上。
I think it's Burbank. And it's very cool, old school. Have you guys done Apple Pan? You must have done Apple. Yes, of course. But that's over the hill. Yeah, Apple Pan's the best. That's over on Pico.
我要说点有争议的话。有些大家都谈论的汉堡店，它们只不过是……我只是觉得它们真的被高估了。比如？比如？嗯，我不想点名。在……
I'm going to say something controversial. There are burger places that everybody talks about that are only... That I just think are really overrated. Like? Like? Well, I don't want to name it. In an...
In-N-Out？我想抬高大家的兴致，但我不会点名，点那些我不喜欢其名字的东西。这超级，超级勇敢。好吧，我会，你知道的，我会说我们周日的朋友做的汉堡完全不逊色于In-N-Out。噢，天哪。
In and out? I want to raise people's boats, but I'm not going to name people, things that I don't like my name. That's super, super courageous. Well, I will, you know, I will say our friend on Sunday makes a burger very much on par with In and Out. Oh, my God.
确实如此。我认为更好。对。我认为更好。我能同意你的看法。我认为更好。哇。真的很好吃。
It is. I would say better. Yeah. I would say better. I could be with you. I would say better. Wow. It's really delicious.
如果可以的话，我们在这里轮流说一说。如果你只能有一种。经典垃圾食品作为你的最后一餐。会是汉堡吗？会是披萨吗？会是烤奶酪吗？这是个好问题。我先来。我觉得会是
If you could, let's go around the horn here. If you could have only one. classic junk food as your final meal. Would it be like a burger? Would it be pizza? Would it be grilled cheese? That's a great question. I will go first. I think it's going to be
披萨，我还要配一份炸得酥脆的薯条。好的。噢，是的。我来。对，你来。不，你来，肖恩。我选意大利面。好的。真的吗？但那不是垃圾食品。太肖恩·海耶斯了。你知道，这家伙，能给我点冰淇淋吗？对，什么口味的？香草味。
pizza and I'm going to have a side of well-done fries. Okay. Oh yeah. I would do. Yeah, you go. No, you go, Sean. I was spaghetti. Okay. Really? But that's not junk food. It's so Sean Hayes. You know, this guy, can I have some ice cream? Yeah, what flavor? Vanilla.
就是这样。那是他的最爱。他太喜欢了。好吧，你知道为什么。母乳。那是母乳。克尔斯滕，你会选什么？你的终极垃圾食品是什么？
That's it. That's his goat. He loves it so much. Well, you know why. Mother's milk. It's mother's milk. Kirsten, what would you have? What would you be your ultimate junk food?
嗯，垃圾食品。就像舒适食物。对，对，对，对，对。我想老实说，我可能会选In-N-Out。对。芝士汉堡。我喜欢。只要单层的吗？
Well, junk food. Like comfort food. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I think I honestly, I might do in and out. Yeah. Cheeseburger. I love it. Just a single?
嗯，芝士汉堡，多加酱，不要洋葱，这就是我的风格。所以不要双层双份。不要。不过要多加酱。我喜欢你的巧克力。风格。你可不是把酱放在旁边那种。你要他们直接抹在上面。对的。对，对，对。你得快点吃，不然面包会变湿。对，这就是为什么我买外卖回家时会关掉空调。我就会想：关掉空调。最好把袋子卷得紧紧的。我讨厌人们拿着打开的In-N-Out盒子回家。我也讨厌。有什么意义？退回去。退回去，因为你想让汉堡保持热度？是的。天哪，我爱你。这简直提升了一个高度。这真的很有趣。在这点上我和你一样。等等，我能回到工作的话题上一会儿吗？不，等等，阿奈特还没宣布呢。噢，对，抱歉。我也选披萨。
Well, cheeseburger, extra spread, no onions is my vibe. So not the double double. No. Extra spread, though. I like your chocolate. style. You're not doing the spread on the side. You want them to slather it right on. Yes. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You got to eat it quick for the bun get soggy. Yeah, that's why I turn the air conditioning off when I get takeout for home. I'm like, AC off. It better be rolled up in the bag real tight. I hate when people come home with an open box of in and out. I do too. What's the point? Take it back. Take it back because you want to keep your burger hot? Yes. God, I love you. That is an extra level. That is really interesting. I'm with you on that. Wait, can I go back to work for a second? No, wait, Arnette hasn't declared. Oh, yeah, sorry. I'd go pizza, too.
我选披萨和巧克力奶昔。那是什么种类的披萨？可能就是个，多半就是一个芝士披萨。对。也许加点肉，香肠。来点好吃的肉。我想要点香肠和洋葱。那是酥脆的还是那种软底的？
I'd go pizza and chocolate shake. And what kind of pizza is it? It would probably be just a, more than likely, just a cheese pizza. Yeah. Maybe with some meat on it, a sausage. So some nice meat. I was some sausage and some onions. Is that a crispy or is that kind of a soft?
不，正如他们所说，它必须有一种酥脆的底层。边缘烤焦。不一定，不一定。边缘焦黑，但我的必须带点酥脆才行。而且，当我看到人们吃披萨把饼皮放在一边不吃时，我就想，你是，你是共产主义者吗？你在干什么？上大学时，我通常把披萨吃完，然后把饼皮留着，之后蘸花生酱吃。
No, it's got to have a sort of a crispy undercarriage, as they say. Black barred. Not necessarily, not necessarily. black bottom, but I just got to have some crispy to do it. And I, when I see people eat pizza and put the crust to the side and they don't eat the crust, I'm like, are you, are you a communist? What do you doing? In college, I used to eat the pizza and then save the crust and dip it in peanut butter after.
咦。天哪，你这个混蛋，猪猡。花生酱？对，因为那只是面包。我是说，我是带着全部的，全部的尊敬说这话的。你这个死胖子。等等，我想问更多关于工作的事。是克尔斯滕·邓斯特。
Ew. God, you shit, pig. Peanut butter? Yeah, like, because it was just bread. I mean, I mean this with all, with all respect. You fat fuck. Wait, I want to ask more work stuff. It's Kirsten Dants.
我知道，我知道，我也是。我想问，我想问我自己。我想知道，你在拍摄前、拍摄后、拍摄期间，有没有什么例行要做的事情，或者有什么是一直坚持的，比如，你知道的，我马上要开始一份工作了，所以事情会这样发展。我一定要确保做到某某某。比如练习你的表情或者……
I know, I know, me too. I want to ask, I want to ask me. I want to know, do you have any kind of routine things that you do before a shoot, after shoot, during a shoot, or something that you're consistent about that, like, you know, I'm about to start a job, so this is how this is going to go. I'm going to make sure I do blank, blank, blank. Like practicing your faces or...
对着镜子里。对。我做的任何事。你很注重做研究吗？你很注重，比如获取并研究你的角色的性格，琢磨他们口袋里装了什么，以及所有那些演员的把戏吗？他们有一个秘密。我的角色有一个秘密。
In the mirror. Yeah. Anything I do. Are you big on research? You big on, like, getting and studying your kids? character and figuring out what they have in their pockets and all that actor stuff. They have a secret. My characters have a secret.
我，我做什么？我做梦境工作。这是我做的主要事情。噢，是的，我喜欢这个。那是什么？什么是梦境工作？我刚刚第一次说。是吗？
I, what do I do? I do dream work. That's my main thing I do. Oh, yeah, I like that. What's that? What is dream work? I just said the first time. You did?
对。对。那是大卫·格芬创办的公司吗？对，梦境工作。等等，克尔斯滕，什么是真的？我不知道什么是梦境工作。所以有几个你可以找的表演教练。他们不仅于此，但我的那位女士是做过这个的，她妈妈也做过这个，然后
Yeah. Yeah. Is that the company that was started by David Geffen? Yeah, dream work. Wait, Kirsten, what is true? I don't know what dream work is. So there's a couple acting coaches you could call. them but they're more than that but my lady is someone who's done it her mom did it too and
你基本上就是问自己问题，晚上给自己写一张便签，写下你想了解关于你的角色的什么，然后无论你梦到了什么，你把它写下来，跟她讨论，并把它应用到，噢，那太酷了。剧本里，真的太酷了。但无论这个梦是否和那个问题或你的角色有任何关系，它只是无论你的梦境场景是什么，你都把它融入到你角色的背景故事里。嗯，你晚上会给自己写一张特定的便签。所以你在要求你的潜意识给你一些你可以应用的东西。
you basically ask your self questions and write yourself a note at night of what you want to find out about your character and then whatever you dream you write it down and you discuss it with her and implement it into oh that's cool the script that's really cool but but regardless of whether the dream had anything to do with the question or your character It's just whatever your dream scenario was, you kind of incorporated into your character's backstory. Well, you're writing yourself a specific note at night. So you're asking your unconscious to give you something that you can implement.
对。明白了。太酷了。然后当你拍完电影，你给自己写个便签，我演完这个角色了，巴拉巴拉，然后签退。这就是你的例行程序。这就是你做的事情。对。
Yeah. Gotcha. That's cool. And then when you're done with the movie, you write yourself a note, I'm done with this character, blah, blah, blah, and sign out. There's your routine. There's your thing that you do. Yeah.
这挺酷的。确实挺酷的。马上回来。现在回到节目中。你擅长记台词吗？我越来越差了。对。我太差了。
That's pretty rad. That is pretty cool. be right back. And now back to the show. Are you good at remembering lines? I'm getting worse. Yeah. I'm so bad.
这会降临到我们每个人头上。真的吗？我变得这么差，如果我读剧本，里面的人台词很多，我就会想，我不知道我能不能演。所以如果有人给你百老汇的一人秀？噢，见鬼不。见鬼不。
It's coming for all of us. Really? I'm getting so bad that if I read a script and the person talks a lot, I'm like, I don't know if I can do this. So if somebody brought you a one-woman show on Broadway? Oh, hell no. Hell no.
不，不。我们的好哥们约翰·卡拉辛斯基刚刚演了一个。他把我惊艳到了。天哪，那太棒了吗？简直他妈的难以置信。看起来，还有比利·克鲁德普也演过好多次。对，都是男演员。
No, no. Our buddy John Krasinski just did one. He knocked me out. My God, is that awesome? Just fucking unreal. It looks like the, and Billy Krodoop's done it a bunch of times. Yeah, there are both men.
你看，女人会多任务处理。不，劳拉·琳妮演过好几次。她演得很棒。你能行的。我不知道。这对我来说很奇怪。我不喜欢演话剧的想法。那要付出很多工作。
See, women multitask. No, Laura Linney's done it a few times. She's nailed it. You can do it. I don't know. It's weird to me. I don't like the idea of doing a play. It's a lot of work.
说实话。那要付出很多工作，对吧，肖恩？我是说，肖恩刚刚结束了差不多两年半的话剧演出。听起来太让人疲惫了。我演了200多场。你还好吗？你因此拿了个托尼奖。
Let's be honest. It's a lot of work, right, Sean? I mean, Sean just came off basically two and a half years of doing this play. That sounds so. tiring to me. I did it over 200 times. Are you okay? You got a Tony out of it.
拿了个托尼奖。对。我是说，至少你拿了托尼奖。我是说，我明白你的意思，克尔斯滕。这确实是，你知道的，财务方面。你不是为了金钱才去的，因为戏剧不赚钱，但你这样做是因为作为一个演员，内心有一种东西，否则你可能不会得到这个机会，或者你能把那个你一直想演的角色从你体内释放出来。
Got a Tony. Yeah. I mean, at least you got the Tony. I mean, I know what you mean, Kirsten. It is, you know, finance. You don't do it for the financial because theater doesn't pay, but you do it because of a thing inside as an actor that you just wouldn't otherwise get the opportunity maybe or you get that character that you've always wanted to play out of you.
所以你会觉得，太棒了，我做到了。现在完成了。现在我可以去演另一个角色了。你有没有想过观众会评判你？比如，噢，那个人只是来看《蜘蛛侠》里的那个女孩。你知道我的意思吗？比如，我觉得有点怪。《蜘蛛侠》里的那个女孩，那是那出戏的名字。
So you're like, great, I did that. And now it's done. and now I can go do maybe another character. Do you ever think about the audience judging you, though? Like, oh, that person's just coming to see the girl from Spider-Man. You know what I mean? Like, I feel like a little weird. The girl from Spider-Man, that's the name of the play.
我只是，我不知道。也许等我老了，我会喜欢它。听着，我做过的仅有的现场直播之一就是《周六夜现场》，那是我一生中最快乐的时光。但我从小看着那个节目长大，真的可以说是我一生中最快乐的时光之一。那次经历怎么样？我有我人生中最美好的时光之一。不，我是说，具体点，比如，那是什么，对。
I just, I don't know. It's just, maybe when I'm older, I'll like it. Listen, one of the only live things I did was Saturday Night Live ones, and I had the best time of my life. But I grew up watching that show, like literally one of the best times of my life. How was that experience? I had one of the best sides of my lot. No, but I mean, like, specifically, like, what was the, yeah.
嗯，我从小看着这个节目长大，我的孩子们现在也一样，他们会叫出一些人的名字，然后说，你知道的，你能为我播放比尔·哈德的木偶小品吗？你知道的？我给他们看克里斯·法利喝哥伦比亚咖啡的那段，你知道，无咖啡因哥伦比亚咖啡发疯的那段。等等，我得看看那个。那是史上最好笑的小品之一。我们以前管我们老幺叫，好吧，他是小克里斯·法利。但我不知道我要说什么了。你在谈论你在SNL度过的那个星期的具体细节，你喜欢什么。
Well, I grew up watching the show, as do my kids now, they'll call out people and be like, you know, will you put on the Bill Hader puppet sketch for me, you know? Like, I show them Chris Farley with the Colombian coffee, you know, the decaf Colombian coffee freaking. Wait, I got to see that. It's one of the funniest sketches ever. We used to call our youngest, well, he's baby Chris Farley. But I don't know where I'm going with this. You were talking about the specifics of what you loved about the week on SNL.
所以我当时，我小的时候，当达纳·卡维在沙发上扮演老布什时，我演了他的孙子，就像个临时演员一样坐在那儿吃爆米花。我还和维多利亚·杰克逊一起。对，谢谢。在她的一则恶搞广告里也有我。所以这对我的家族来说简直是个传承。对，感觉。你主持的时候他们放那个片段了吗？
So I was, when I was younger, I played Data Carvey's grandchild when he was George Bush on the couch, like eating popcorn as an extra. And I was with Victoria. Jackson. Yeah, thank you. In one of her spoof commercials, too. So it's like such a legacy thing for my family. Yeah, it felt. Did they show that clip when you hosted?
对，他们放了。不会吧。对。噢，太酷了。而且在，当你走的时候，就像主走廊里，当你到达那里时，小小的我和达纳·卡维一起坐在沙发上。真可爱。那是其中一个，对，太棒了，我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。
Yeah, they did. No way. Yeah. Oh, that's cool. And it's in the, when you walk, like in the main hallway, when you get there, little me is in with Dana Carvey on the couch. That's cute. It was one of the, yeah, it was so, I loved it so much. I loved it.
太棒了。所以，是的。当你没在拍电影之类的东西以及当妈妈的时候，你都做些什么？你知道的，你，你最喜欢做什么？你用什么来填满你的时间？你只是觉得什么都不做，购物，在托卢卡漫步吗？老实说，前几天我把他们送去学校，我去练了普拉提，做完这些后我就看电视。我想躺在床上看电视，就是这样。我不想做个我不想在这里做一个
That's great. So, yes. What do you do when you're not working on films and stuff and momming? You know, do you, what do you love to do? What do you feel your time with? You're just like nothing, shopping, walking around Toluca. I honestly the other day I dropped them off I went to Pilates I did that and then I just watch TV I want to lay in bed and watch TV that's all I don't want to make a I don't want to make a
概括，一个性别偏见？但你还是会做。但你会做，但我会，你知道的，我会在这里这会是个不错的解围方式。前几天有人告诉我，他们注意到我，我只谈论我自己的家。阿曼达所有的电视都是在床上看的。我所有的电视都是在沙发上看的。对，我觉得这并不罕见。我这话说的挺好，不是吗？你做得真好。为什么你觉得这不是一件罕见的事？你是说跟性别有关吗？好吧，肖恩说了。不，我不知道你在说什么。还是……或者只是人，或者只是人，或者就像人，人们喜欢看我试过在床上看电视
generalization here a sexist but you're gonna but you're gonna but I'm gonna you know I'm gonna here this would be a good bailout somebody told me the other day they noticed that I'll just talk about my own house. Amanda watches all of her TV in bed. I watch all of my TV on the couch. Yeah, and I find that that is not uncommon. I said that pretty
我觉得我好像要长褥疮了，我需要经常翻身。我一直认为床是用来睡觉的，所以如果我开始在床上看电视，那就会扰乱我的睡眠。它会把你弄晕，除非电视开着。
well, didn't I? You did a really good job. Why do you think that is an uncommon thing? As it relates to gender, you mean? Okay, Sean said it. No, I didn't know what you were. Or is it... Or just peep or just peep or just like peep something. people like to watch I've tried to watch TV in bed
不把电视开着他根本睡不着。斯科蒂不能。对，我不知道。我马上就来，等一下。对，对，你，你睡觉时会开着电视吗？
and I feel like I'm getting like bed sores like I need to be able to shift around a lot I always think the bed is for sleeping and so that if I start watching something in bed then it's going to mess with my sleep and it'll knock you out unless the TV's on
你睡觉时会开着电视吗，克尔斯滕？不，不。不过你卧室里有电视对吧？见鬼，当然有。对，见鬼，当然有。有些人没有。我们有一个。杰西看吗？
he cannot fall asleep unless the TV's on Scottie can't yeah I don't know I'm going to be right with you hold on yeah yeah do you do you fall asleep with the TV
对。为了睡觉？不，不是为了睡觉，就是为了享受。但是，你呢，因为我和阿曼达经常会这样入睡：她在看她的iPad，而我在看电视。但她必须戴上他妈的耳机。我想拍张照片。这样她就能听见她的iPad，而听不到我在电视上听的东西。但这通常只能持续大约10分钟。
do you fall asleep with the TV on Kirsten no no you got a TV in the bedroom though Hell yeah. Yeah, hell yeah. Some people don't. We got one. Does Jesse watch it?
但那是在沙发上。她跟你一起在房间里，她在沙发上。不，不，这是当我最终上楼钻进被窝的时候。你把电视打开？当你躺在床上时。对，她已经开始用iPad了。我得拿她的耳机给她。她戴上耳机，然后我把电视打开，让它伴我入眠。
Yeah. To go to sleep? No, not to go to sleep, just to enjoy. But what about, will you, because Amanda and I often fall asleep where she's watching her iPad and then I'm watching the TV. But she's got to have the fucking headphones on. I want a photo of that. So that she can hear her iPad and not hear what I'm listening to on the TV. But it really only lasts about 10 minutes.
你们俩应该尝试一种叫互相说话的东西。哈？好吧，你在干什么？建立联系，杰森。让我过来帮帮你们的婚姻。给我10分钟帮帮你们的婚姻。克尔斯滕，有没有哪个是你梦想合作但还没合作过的？因为看起来你已经和所有伟大的，伟大的人合作过了。
But that's on the couch. She's down in your room with you and she's on the couch. No, no, this is when I eventually go upstairs and I get in bed. And you turn the TV? When you're in bed. Yeah, she's got the iPad already going. I've got to bring her headphones. She puts those on, and then I turn on the TV and let it rock me out.
我是说，其中一位是保罗·托马斯·和森。我觉得到处都能听到这个名字。听说那部新电影会很厉害。对，看起来太酷了。但他推荐我演了《忧郁症》。所以那很酷。噢，我们做过。噢，那很酷。好吧，杰西可以为你美言几句。
You guys should try something called talking to each other. Huh? Well, what are you? Relating, Jason. Let me come over and help your marriage. Just give me 10 minutes to help your marriage. Kirsten, is there somebody that you dreamed of working with that you haven't with? Because it seems like you've worked with all the great, like great, great people.
他至少和他合作过一次。我是说，我有他的电话号码。他有时会随机给我发邮件，所以我把那些都存着。只是开始随机给他发你这些年来的头部大头照。他确实这么做了。他有一次打电话给我，他说，我有些事想跟你谈谈。然后我就想，噢，天哪。就像，这事要成了。
I mean, the one is Paul Thomas Anderson. I feel like that's everywhere. I hear that new movie is going to be the thing. Yeah, it looks sick. But he did recommend me for melancholia. So that was cool. Oh, we did. Oh, that's cool. Well, Jesse could put in a good word for you.
然后我们玩了很久的电话塔。最后我们终于联系上了。他问我跟另一个演员合作是什么感觉。噢。因为他在考虑给那个人工作。我就想，你知道你那样做有多刻薄吗？对。那样做可太不酷了。
He's working them at least once. I mean, I have his phone number. He randomly emails me sometimes, so I have those saved. Just starts sending him just random headshots of you from over the years. He did. He called me once, and he was like, I need to talk to you about something. And I was like, oh, my God. Like, this is going to happen.
我无法想象那种压力。他一定感受到了巨大的压力，就像他交谈过的每一个演员。对。都在向他套近乎。这是我的时刻吗？对。对。我能做些什么来给他留下好印象？
And then we played phone tag forever. And then we finally got in touch. And he was like, asked me about what it was like working with this other actor. Oh. Because he's thinking about giving them a job. I was like, you know how mean that was of you? Yeah. That was not cool to do that.
对。嗯哼。我知道。好吧，机会会来的。听着，这也会发生的。你可以显化任何事情。我是说，这当然会发生。是这样吗？威尔，宇宙是怎么说的？顺便说一句，这是真的。噢，你不需要挑起眉毛。你在谈论显化？你想为这事跟我打一架吗？把你关于显化的论点说出来。把它说出来。你说，向宇宙索取你想要的东西，它就会发生？对，你知道我总是说什么吗？为什么不是我？为什么不是我？
I can't imagine the pressure. He must feel so much pressure like every actor that he ever talks to. Yeah. They're just hitting on him. Is this my moment? Yeah. Yeah. What can I do to make a good impression on him?
好吧，你为什么就让他们？你知道吗？我也能爱他们。罗宾·麦格劳。我们马上回来。对。我们最近一直在这样做，当我们试图进广告时。就像，我们马上回来。等等，你是怎么，你想象过，你和杰西是怎么认识的吗？我们在《冰血暴》第二季中认识的。
Yeah. Mm-hmm. I know. Well, it'll come. Listen, it'll happen, too. You can manifest anything. I mean, of course it's going to happen. Is that right? Will, what is the universe say about? By the way, it's true. Oh, you don't need to raise your eyebrows up. You're talking about manifest? You want to fucking fight me on this? Give me your pitch on manifestation. Put it out there. Put it out there. You're saying, ask the universe for what you want and it's going to happen? Yeah, you know what I always say? Why not me? Why not me?
噢。对。而且我们，太搞笑了我记得在机场看到他，比如我们在洛杉矶国际机场见面。第一次见面，历历在目。我们只是。他不记得是这样的吗？你说过感觉他好像不记得了。不，不，我只是觉得，你通常不会记得跟某人的第一次见面。
Well, why do you just let them? You know? I could love them, too. Mal Robbins. And we'll be right back. Yeah. We've been doing this lately where we try to go to commercial. Just like, and we'll be right back. Wait, how did you, did you imagine, how did you and Jesse meet? We met on Fargo, season two.
你能在脑海中非常清晰地画出来。对。好吧，但你能说说为什么你记得那么清楚吗？我不知道为什么。这就像那种感觉，就像，虽然我记得那个时刻，尽管我当时并不知道这就是我的未来丈夫，你知道。什么时候开始调情的？能告诉我们吗？
Oh. Yep. And we, it's so funny, I remember seeing him at the airport, like us meeting at L.A.X. For the first time, so clearly. We just were. He doesn't remember it that way? You said that it's almost like he doesn't remember. No, no, I just like, you don't often remember meeting the first meeting with someone.
嗯，调情。就像，我觉得我们非常，就像，灵魂伴侣。在我们的角色中也有这种契合。但也包括我们合作的方式，我当时想的是，我不想离开他身边，我是这么想的。我喜欢这样。对，甚至在吃午饭的时候，我会想，你午饭吃什么，你知道的。管他呢，我们在工场做个三明治吧，无所谓。谁先问对方是否处于恋爱关系中的？
You could picture it in your brain really clearly. Yeah. Well, but can you say why you remember it so clearly? I don't know why. It's like one of those things that like, while I remember that moment, even though I didn't know this was my future husband, you know. When did the flirt start? Can you tell us?
我们俩心里都有数，哦，我们当时都处在恋爱关系中。对，所以整个过程都非常尊重对方。对，完全尊重。然后我们只是保持联系。后来两个人都结束了各自的恋情。我们直到一年后才真正在一起。好的。对。
Uh, the flirt. Like, I think we were so, like, soulmate. a mesh kind of in our characters, too. But also the way we worked, and I just felt like I didn't want to not be near him, is what I thought. I love that. Yeah, even at lunchtime, like, I'd be like, what are you doing for lunch, you know? Whatever, let's make a sandwich at Crafty because, whatever. Who asked who first whether they were involved in a relationship?
对。西南偏南音乐节是我们第一次一起玩。嗯哼。收到。炎热的奥斯汀夏夜。回到第一点。你知道的。嗯哼。
We both kind of knew, oh, we were both in relationships. Right, so then it was respectful all the way through. Yeah, totally respectful. And then we just kept in touch. And then both were out of our relationships. We didn't get together till a year after. Okay. Yeah.
还在录。这倒也是。如果我们不聊聊《屋顶人》，那就太失职了。所以，JB，你看过这部电影，太棒了。我看过这部电影，我给它一个大大的，大大的赞。大大的赞。由伟大的德里克·斯安弗朗斯执导，对吧？由查宁·塔图姆联袂主演。
Yeah. South by Southwest was our first hang out. Uh-huh. Copy that. Hot Austin Summer Nights. Back to one. You know. Uh-huh.
对。这是个真实故事，讲的是一个家伙在玩具反斗城里住了好几个月？是的，他确实这么做了。他基本上通过屋顶吃了大概45顿麦当劳。这就是为什么他们叫他“屋顶人”。对，这都是真的。真的吗？对，他在玩具反斗城里躲了六个月。
Still rolling. That's fair. We'd be remiss if we didn't talk a little bit about Roofman. So, J.B., you saw this movie, it's amazing. I saw this movie, I give it a huge, huge thumbs up. Huge thumbs up. Directed by the great Derek Sanfrance, right? And co-starring Channing Tatum.
对。这就像，而且，你知道我，我是个黑暗的白痴。所以我一直等着这部电影变得有点吓人、凄凉、黑暗和犯罪。但这部电影有着非常棒的精神内核和温暖感，尽管它是围绕着一个角色展开的。
Yep. It's a based on a true story about a dude who lives inside of Toys R Us for a couple months? Yes, he does. He basically raw up like 45 McDonald's through the roof. That's why they call him The Roof Man. Yeah, this is all true. Really? Yeah, and he hid out in a Toys R Us for six months.
你知道的，一直在违法乱纪，它不像那种明目张胆的罗宾汉式的替天行道，但也有点那种意思。不过整个过程中有一种非常棒的基调，德里克·斯安弗朗斯在整部电影中贯穿了这种基调，简直就像
Yeah. It's like, and it's, you know, like, you know me, I'm a dark idiot. And so I keep waiting for this film to get, like, kind of scary and bleak and dark and crime. But it's so, this film has such a great spirit and warmth about it, even though it's centralized around a character. that's you know breaking the law left and right and it's not like an overtly sort of robin hood thing where they kind of earn it all but it kind of is but there's just such great like there's like a tone throughout it that that derrick see and francis just like pulls through it that is just like
高空走钢丝一样，太酷了。克尔斯滕，你和查宁在保持这种基调上也做得太棒了。就好像，我不知道，我觉得这是世上最难的事情之一，能让一部作品自始至终都保持迷人且引人入胜。对，而且不显得矫揉造作、老套或具有操纵性。对，对。它从来不会过于一本正经，尽管它是一部非常温暖的电影。它，我不知道，这很难形容，但我强烈推荐。真的，对，而且克尔斯滕，我喜欢这样。
such a high wire act that's so cool and kirsten you and channing do such a great job of maintaining that too it's like i don't know i think it's just one of the hardest things in the world to keep something winning and watchable all the way through. Yeah, and not be like sappy or corny or feel manipulative. Yeah, yeah. It never gets earnest, although it's a very warm movie. It's, I don't know, it's very hard to describe, but I highly recommend it. It's really, yeah, and Kirsten, I love that.
我已经迫不及待想看了。只要你一直在工作，你是否发现自己不管是否能署名，都会不知不觉地承担起某种制片人的角色？当你选择表演工作时，这意味着我喜欢这个角色，我想见导演或诸如此类的事情，但我对如何改进我在其中的角色有一些想法，以便它适合我或者诸如此类的事情。
I can't wait to see it. Do you find yourself as long as you've worked kind of integrating yourself towards whether you get credit for it or not, a producerial kind of role? when you choose your acting gigs, meaning I like this part, I want to meet with the director or whatever it is, but I have these things to say about how to improve my role in it so that it works for me or whatever the thing is.
我是说，我在一个电视剧里这样做过，但我觉得我拍的那两部电影，《屋顶人》和飞机那部电影，剧本已经太成熟了，所以其实没怎么……对，你只会觉得太棒了，对。对，我是说，只要是德里克导演的，我什么都愿意演。对。所以这并不是一个我天生可能会倾向于接演的角色，但我还是想再次为了那段经历与他合作。
I mean, I did that on a TV show, but I feel like it's both those movies that I did, Roof Man and the plane movie were so developed that it's not really, you know. Yeah, you're just like great, yeah. Yeah, I mean, I would have done anything with Derek. Right. So this isn't a part personally that I would naturally maybe gravitate towards, but I wanted to, again, work with him for the experience.
就像，我只是，对，那是……跟她合作符合你的一切期望吗？是的，是的，是的。怎么样？对。当那种情况发生时真是太酷了。我想再次与他合作。对，他是个好人。
Like, I just, yeah, that's... Was it everything you hoped it would be working with him? Yes, yes, yes. How about that? Yeah. That's so cool when that happens. I want to work with him again. Yeah, here he's a great guy.
我从没见过他。查宁简直是史上最棒的。我爱死他了。对吧？他真是个好人。是的，他是个真性情的人，对。所以，我是说，老实说，而且显然德里克是个非常伟大的电影制作人，他的电影都是那种小巧的电影。
I've never met him. And Channing is just, like, the greatest ever. I love him. Right? He is such a good dude. Yes, he's one of the real ones, yeah. So, I mean, honestly, and obviously Derek is such a great filmmaker, and his movies are kind of little movies.
当我说这个的时候，我不是指在，我只是指相比于如今拍出来的那些基于IP或者别的什么的巨制大片，他拍的是那种非常棒的、由角色驱动的小成本电影。你，正如我们之前提到的，你把这些都演遍了。对，太惊人了。两者你都有出色的表现。
And when I say that, I don't mean in terms of, just in terms of like the, compared to some of these huge movies that get made these days that are all, like, based on IP and whatever, he has these really great little story-driven movies that he makes with great characters. Do you, and you've done all of, as we mentioned before. Yeah, it's amazing. You've got great stance and both, yeah.
对。现在，当你寻找工作时，当你坐在这里，待在家里，杰西出去工作了，你在想，好吧，我要进行下一项工作了。你有什么计划吗？你会想，接下来我要达到这种高度，还是就只是等待？
Yeah. Now when you look to do stuff, so as you sit here and you're at home and Jesse's off working and you're thinking, okay, I'm going to do my next thing. Do you have a plan? Do you go like, I want to kind of hit this note next or do you just kind of wait?
我有点在等待，但我也想做点有趣的事。比如，我只是想找点乐子。而且，对，我想拍个喜剧或者拍点宏大有趣的东西。为什么，而且，你知道的，这就是我们在节目中有时会谈论的事情。比如，那些电影都在哪？为什么他们不再拍那些宏大、有趣、众星云集的厂牌喜剧了？
I kind of wait, but also I'd like to do something fun. Like, I just want to have fun. And I, yeah, I want to do like a comedy or do something big and fun. And why, and, you know, like, that's the thing we talk about in the show sometimes. Like, where are those movies? Why do they not make those big fun studio ensemble comedies anymore?
我觉得他们很快就会拍的。我觉得他们必须拍。对，因为我们周围的世界太黑暗了。对。确实如此。我觉得人们只需要……我觉得人们会想要渴望，或者开始渴望那种东西。我不知道什么时候，但我认为……
I think they will soon. I think they have to. Yeah, because the world around us is too dark. Yeah. It sure is. I think people just have to... I think people are going to want to crave or going to start craving that. I don't know when, but I think...
我知道我接下来想导演一部喜剧。我觉得，你知道，有时……谁在谈论这个？就像这种观点：当我们处于黑暗时期时，人们对这些宏大的、动作感十足的、有趣的、妙趣横生的电影的胃口没有那么大，因为它们不是人们所处的状态，而且这往往是一种反映——如果一切在我们的文化中感觉都很平静，那么我们就可以直接去拍那些疯狂搞笑的蠢事；而当不平静时，人们很难抽离。这很奇怪
I know I want to direct a comedy next. I think it, you know, sometimes... Who is I talking about this? Like this idea that when we're in times that are dark, people don't have as much of an appetite for these big sort of... of actiony fun pithy movies because they because it's not where they're at and and uh it's often a reflection of like if everything sort of feels calm in in in our culture then we can just kind of go and do these big goofy things and when it's not calm it's hard for people to let go it's weird
因为你本以为他们会想要逃避现实，但其实并没有。对，恐怖电影现在实际上卖得很好。给你，武器。噢，天哪，那部电影真好。对，你喜欢那部《武器》。我喜欢。你喜欢那部《武器》。我知道。你看过那部电影吗，克尔斯滕，《武器》？我还没看过，不。你看电影吗？去杰森家，他每两小时就放一次。你在家里看电影吗？
because you'd think that they'd want to have the escapism but they actually don't yeah like scary movies are actually doing really well there you go weapons oh my god that movie's good yeah you love that weapons i do you love that weapons i know Have you seen that, Kirsten Weapons? I haven't seen it yet, no. Do you watch movies? Go to Jason's house, he's showing it about every two hours. Do you watch movies, though, at home?
你喜欢电影吗？自己看还是和孩子们一起看，诸如此类的？我喜欢去电影院。对，我会带他们去电影院。对，我更愿意去。如果我在家里看电影，我就会睡着。对，你的孩子们看过所有的经典电影吗？比如《E.T.》、《星球大战》，所有那些？你知道的，他们才四岁和。
Do you like movies? By yourself or with your kids or whatever? I like going to the movie theater. Yeah, and I'll take them to the movie theater. Yeah, I'd rather do. If I watch a movie at home, I fall asleep. Yeah, have your kids seen all the classics like E.T. Star Wars, all those things. You know, they're four and.
七岁，七岁，对，还不是那种，但你知道吗，我的小家伙。好吧，我七岁时《星球大战》才上映。嘿，肖恩，她还没给他们看《星球大战》呢。别这样，伙计。操。好吧，继续，抱歉。不，我，我四岁的小儿子喜欢《毒液》，第一部《毒液》，我可能不该给他看这个。太奇怪了。
Seven seven, yeah, it's not like, but you know what, my little guy. Well, I was seven when Star Wars came out. Hey, Sean, she hasn't shown them Star Wars. Don't be it, man. Fuck. Okay, go ahead, sorry. No, I, my four-year-old likes venom, the first venom, which I probably shouldn't have shown him. That's so weird.
太奇怪了，我的小家伙也喜欢。噢，天哪。我五岁的儿子也喜欢《毒液》。真的吗？我是说，我们给他们看这个可能不是好父母，但管他呢。我看《驱魔人》时。我大概八九岁。对，我当时也那么小。
That's so weird, so is my little guy. Oh, my God. My five-year-old likes venom, too. Really? I mean, we're probably not good parents for showing them, but whatever. I saw the exorcist. I was like eight or nine. Yeah, I thought it's that young, too.
我不该看那部电影的。还有，我的孩子一直在哀求我，我四岁的孩子，想看《大白鲨》。我就想，好吧，杰西和我给他看了前十分钟，试图解释那个女孩是被绳子拖着走的。对，然后她在鲨鱼嘴里被活活吃掉了。不，他还是看了。
I should not be seeing that movie. Also, my child was begging me, my four-year-old, to watch Jaws. I was like, okay, Jesse and I showed him the first ten minutes and tried to explain that the girl is being pulled around on a rope. Yeah, and she's getting eaten alive in the shark. No, he went.
他还是看了，对。但我不得不开导他。对。好吧，听着，克尔斯滕，我们占用了你那么多时间。对。这真是，我们，你太讨人喜欢了。
He went. He still went, yeah. But I had to talk about it down. Yeah. Well, listen, Kirsten, we take it away so much of your time. Yeah. This is, we're, you're such a delight.
我是说，我可以跟你们聊好久。我知道，我们可以。不，完全没有压力。我要过去了。我今天下午晚些时候过去。跟我出来喝杯咖啡。你知道，有时那些采访，感觉就像是
I mean, I could talk to you guys for a while. I know, we can. No, zero pressure vibes. I'm coming over. I'm coming over later this afternoon. Come out of coffee with me. You know, sometimes those interviews, they feel like they were,
只有10分钟长。这非常轻松愉快。我知道。杰森他们要来，我们打算顺路去你家，在路上给你带点In-N-Out。谢谢你们，伙计们。
that they're like 10 minutes long. This is not very easy, breezy. I know. Jason and they are coming to, we're going to stop by the house and we'll drop off some in and out for you on our way. Thanks, guys.
那也会热得要命。你知道怎么让一个女孩开心。对。好吧，所以，所以，《屋顶人》将于10月10日上映。我们对此感到非常兴奋。10月10日。还有那部，正如你所说的，飞机电影。
It's going to be hot as shit, too. You know how to make a girl happy. Yeah. All right, so, So, Roof Man is out October 10th. We're really excited about it. October 10th. Also with the, as you called it, the airplane movie.
我忘了它叫什么了。你要为那部电影回来。我想让你回来。对，娱乐系统坏了。我想看那个。对。那么多精彩的事情。你演过那么多伟大的角色。你还在继续这样做。
I forget what it's called. You're going to come back for that. I want you back. Yeah, entertainment system is down. I want to see that. Yeah. So many amazing things. You've done so many great roles. You continue to do it.
你真是太讨人喜欢了。很高兴你能来。对。一段不可思议的职业生涯。一个伟大的人，一个伟大的妈妈，一个伟大的妻子。而且，你什么都能做好。谢谢你们，伙计们。谢谢你们，伙计们。
You're such as a light. So happy to have you here. Yeah. One incredible career. A great person and a great mom and a great wife. And like, you're just doing it all. Thanks, guys. Thanks, guys.
KD。谢谢你加入我们，KD。谢谢你们邀请我。很高兴认识你们。谢谢你，肖恩。再见，伙计们。拜拜，拜拜，拜拜。
KD. Thank you for joining us, KD. Thank you for having me. It's really nice to meet you, Thank you, Sean. You do. Bye, guys. Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye.
我是说，那真的很特别。非常有趣。听众朋友们，你们刚才没有看到那个彩蛋时刻，她和两个小男孩在一起，她最后打开门让他们进来了。他们进来打了个招呼，威尔还模仿了他的乐高蝙蝠侠的声音，
I mean, that was real special. That was a lot of fun. Listener, you didn't see the bonus moment there with the two young boys, and she finally opened up the door and let them in. And they came in and said hi and Will did his Lego Batman voice,
把他们惊艳到了。太有趣了，真的很可爱，非常有趣。我喜欢这样。太可爱了。对。太可爱了。太可爱了。真是个好人。
and it blew their minds. It was fun, really cute, really fun. I love that. So cute. Yeah. So cute. So, so cute. What a nice lady.
你们俩真可爱。你们俩真可爱。真的非常可爱。外面有几个小可爱。伟大的职业生涯。她甚至还没完成一半呢。我知道。噢，天哪。
You guys are cute. You guys are cute. There's a really cute. There are a couple cutie pies out there. Great career. She's not even halfway done. I know. Oh, my God.
你们真可爱。你们真可爱。真的非常可爱。外面有几个小可爱。了不起的职业生涯。她甚至还没完成一半。我知道。噢，天哪。
She's just getting warmed up. Yep. She's just getting warmed up. She's so, I'm so excited for Roof, man. J.B., you've already seen it, but I can't wait to see it. It's going to be so good. Yeah, I want to see it. And then the entertainment system is up.
她才刚开始热身呢。没错。她才刚开始热身。她太——我对鲁夫太兴奋了，伙计。J.B.，你已经看过了，但我等不及要看了。这一定会非常棒。是的，我想看。然后娱乐系统就启动了。
I know, I know. Entertainment system is down. Because what would we do? She's always good. She's one of those people. Always good. Always good. Everything she does.
我知道，我知道。娱乐系统瘫痪了。因为我们还能做什么？她总是表现很好。她是那种人。总是很好。总是很好。她做的每一件事。
Sean, you get that all the time. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, and J.B.? No, no, man, you know. No, no, no, no. 50, 50, 50, yeah. Sometimes you're on, and sometimes you're on stand by.
肖恩，你总是能得到这样的评价。是的。是的。我是说，还有J.B.？不，不，伙计，你懂的。不，不，不，不，五五开，五五开，五五开，对。有时候你表现出色，有时候你得在旁边待命。
Bye! Bye, oh, that's so fast, bye, buddy. Smartless. Smart. Yes. Smartless is 100% organic, and artisanly handcraft. by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarv, and Bennett Barbico. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见！再见，哦，太快了，再见，伙计。Smartless。聪明。是的。Smartless是100%有机且手工制作的，由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿尔马亚夫和本内特·巴比科完成。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。